لقاء ثلاثي غير مسبوق في موسكو جمعه وزراء
دفاع روسيا وتركيا وسوريا اجريت فيه
مباحثات بمشاركه قاده الاجهزه
الاستخباراتيه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ذكرت
ان الاجتماع بحث السهول حل الازمه السوريه
ومشكله اللاجئين وجهود مكافحه من وصفتهم
بالمجموعات المتطرفه وان المشاركين وصفوا
اجواء الاجتماع بالبناءه واكد على ضروره
استمرار الحوار بهدف تحقيق الاستقرار في
سوريا ولم يتاخر تاكيد الجانب التركي لما
ذكرته موسكو لا يبدو الاجتماع مفاجئا
للنظر الى تصريحات الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان منتصف شهر ديسمبر الجاري على
اردوغان انه اقترح على الرئيس الروسي
بلادي ميرور بوتين تاسيس ما وصفها بالاليه
الثلاثيه مع سوريا لتسريع المسار
الدبلوماسيه بين انقره ودمشق الرئيس
التركي اوضح وقتها ذلك المسار بان تجتمع
اجهزه مخابرات الدول الثلاثه اولا ثم
يتبعه لقاء على مستوى وزراء الدفاع ثم
وزراء الخا ثم قمه على مستوى القاده
نيه تركيا الذهاب في هذا الاتجاه كان اول
مظاهرها في شهر اب اغسطس الماضي وقت هذا
وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود شاوش اوغلو
الى ما قال انه تحقيق المصالحه بين النظام
السوري والمعارضه ثم عادت شاوش اوغلو وذكر
ان مقصد كلامه هو التاكيد على ضروره
التوصل الى تسويه للازمه السوريه وزير
الخارجيه التركي كشف انذاك على لقاء وصفه
بالخاطفي مع وزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل
المقداد عام 2021 على هامش اجتماعي حركه
عدم الانحياز ذلك اللقاء بين الشاوش اوغلو
وفيصل المقداد هو اول اتصال دبلوماسيين
بين انقره ودمشق بعد انقطاعه عقيبا انطلاق
الثوره السوريه